[موسيقى]
تعالوا نلعب لعبه في هنا صورتين لشخصين
مصريين كل واحد فيهم ناجح في المجال
بتاعه
ممكن كده اللي يعرف الشخصيه اللي على
الشمال يرفع
ايديه طيب الشخصيه اللي على اليمين طيب
الشخصيه على الشمال ده ممثل مصري اسمه
كريم عبد العزيز والشخصيه على اليمين ده
شخص ناجح برض في المجال بتاعه واسمه عبد
الرحمن
محمد عبد الرحمن محمد من اول الناس اللي
استخدم تقنيه ال في الذكاء الصناعي دي
التقنيه حاليا مستخدمه في كل ما بتسمعوه
حوالين الاي اي
حاليا ف تعالوا نتكلم على الاي اي شويه في
30 نوفمبر
2022 اصدرت شركه اوبن اي اي برنامج اسمه
تات جي بي
تيي بي تي نقل الحديث عن ذكاء الاصطناعي
بشكل عام من المعامل بتاعه الشركات
والجامعات الى احاديث الناس اليوميه فانا
من كام يوم كنت بكلم
من كم شهر سوري كنت بتكلم مع واحد قريبي
عن الذكاء الاصطناعي وعن الاي اي زي ما
الواحد بيعمل اليومين دول وكان فوجئ لما
عرف ان في مصريين كتير رواد في المجال ده
فانا قلتله ازاي مش عارف لو انت عارف
اسامي ممثل ممثل في مصر ماتعرفش اصلا ان
في حد اي اي في المجال فده خليني افكر اني
اعمل ويب
سايت بيحتفل بال مصر المصريين الكبار
والرواد في مجال الذكاء الصناعي فزي ما
شايفين هنا ده بعض الصور الموجوده في
الناس موجوده على الويب سايت في ناس غيرهم
كتير وانا هتكلم على اليب سايت اكت بعدين
بس تعالوا الاول نتكلم على يعني ايه اصلا
ذكاء
الصناعي فالذكاء
الصناعي الكلمه نفسها اتغيرت ح عبر الزمن
ففي العقود اللي فاتت كان ليها معاني
كتيره بس حاليا لما حد بيتكلم عن ذكاه
الصناعي بيتكلم عن حاجه اسمها ماين
ليرنينج او تدريب الاله ف ببساطه بدل ما
ندي للكمبيوتر قواعد معينه عشان يعرف يفرق
مثلا بين صوره قطه وصوره كلب فحنا هنا
بديله امثله كتيره لص صور كلاب وصور قطط
فهو من خلال الداتا اللي بتجيله بيعرف
ازاي ايه الحاجات اللي يبص عليها عشان
نعرف فرق بين القطه وبين الكلب فهنا بدل
ما نديله قواعد معينه بنقوله اتع انت
قواعد لوحدك من خلال الداتا
الموجوده طيب الم
زي هي مبنيه حاجه اسمها دي منتهى بساطه
نصوص كتيره
من كتير الرنت وحاول تتوقع ايه النص اللي
جاي جايه من النصوص اللي شافتها قبل كده
فكل تشوف نصوص كتيره كل ما بتعرف تم عن
العالم
بتاعنا فزي لو استخدمت هتعرفوا ان ممكن
تعملوا حوارات كتيره معاها وده مجرد من
خلال انها شافت حورات كتيره ودات كتيره
عن
عن عن العالم بشكل عام
يعني
اوكي فين الاي اي في العالم حاليا الحقيقه
ان ناس كتير بتستخدم ذك من غير ما تعرف
اصلا او لو استخدمتوا سي دي او او الكسا
مثلا فده نوع من الذكاء الاصطناعي طب لو
استخدمتوا
مثلا جوجل مابس عشان تعرفوا مثلا وقت
هياخد قد ايه من المهندسين لمصر الجديده
فده برض نع من الذكاء الصناعي طب الجورم
الموجوده على فيسبوك وانستجرام وتويتر
عشان تعرف هتشوف ايه في اللحظه الحاليه دي
ده ذكاء الصناعي يعني الاثله لا حصر لها
وطبعا تجمع اللغه لثانيه ده نوع من الذكاء
الاصطناعي فبشكل عام الذكاء الصناعي كان
موجود في كذا حته ولكن السنه اللي فاتت
حصل طفره كبيره في انواع مزلز معينه اسمها
جيتيف اي
اي فهنا مثلا في الصور اللي انتم شايفينها
دي انا سالت مضل اسمه ستيبل ديفيجن اللي
هو يخلق صوره لحاجه انا فكرت فيها فهنا
قلت له ان هو عايز يتخيل مثلا ناس من مصر
القديمه بتلعب كور قدم قدام الاهرمات
الجيزه فحاجه زي زي كده ما عندهاش صور
ليها ما شافهاش قبل كده ولكن كان عارف
بالمعلومات بالداتا اللي شافها قبل كده
اهرامات الجيزه شكلها
ازاي ان في صحر حوالين اهرامات ان الناس
في مصر القديمه ممكن يكون شكلها عمل ازاي
بتلعب كوره فبالتالي عرف يخلق منظر ممكن
يكون يعني رياليست شويه
فحاجات زيه موجوده كتير قوي في برض حاجات
ممكن ندي لها وصف وتطلع فيديو من الاول او
تطلع مزيكه اا مزيكه لاي او صوت حد بيقول
حاجه جديده فالحاجات دي كلها بطقه تحت
الجف اي
اي طيب الاي اي مش بف هنا هو الحقيقه هو
دلوقتي موجود في مجالات كتيره تانيه فمثلا
في مجال الصيدله الناس بستخدمه عشان تطلع
ادويه جديده ادويه حاجات ما سمعناش عنها
قبل كده مثلا علاج الكانسر او علاج حاجات
تانيه وفي ناس د بستخدمه عشان تعرف تحاول
ازاي ممكن نواجه الحباس
الحراري احسن طرق ممكن نعملها مثلا
فبعمل نوع من الاكسنت كتيره في على
الكمبيوتر قبل ما نعرف نوديها في الحقيقه
وحاجه ده انا مهتم بيها برض هو ازاي نفهم
عن نفسنا ونفهم عن المخ البشري والمخ
البشري من خلاله ممكن نعرف ازاي ممكن نعلج
حاجات زي الزهايمر او ممكن ازاي نعرف احسن
طرق ممكن واجب بيها امراض نفسيه معينه
فالحاجات دي كلها من ضمن الاي اي وليها
تاثير حقيقي على العالم فزي ما شايفين
الاي اي هو فعلا موجود في كل حته ف السؤال
هو ازاي احنا مش عارفين
ناس مصريين بيكونوا في المجالات دي كلها
ده كان بالنسبه لي حاجه كنت عايز يعني
اصلحها شويه يعني ف الحقيقه ممكن اتكلم
الاول شويه عن نفسي عشان ادي لكم فكره انا
مين انا اسمي بدر اتخرجت من الجامعه
الامريكيه كومبيوتر ساينس في
2018 بعد كده دخلت اشتغل
مايكروسوفت بعد كده قرت ماستير في حاجه
مختلفه شويه وهي مجال
اسمه وفكرتها ان كنت بحاول افهم الا اي عن
طريق فهم عن المخ وبعد كده اشتغلت شويه في
سوني اي اي وتا اي اي كباحث في ذكاء
الصناعي واخيرا هتدي دكتوراه في الشهر
الجاي ان شاء الله في سويسرا في جامعه
الحقيقه انا في في اول سنه في الجامعه في
الجامعه الامريكيه كان عندي مشكله ان انا
كنت مهتم قوي بالاي اي بشكل عام وبتك
الصناعي ولكن كان عندي مشكله ان انا ما
كنتش شايف ناس جايه من الخلفيه بتاعتي ناس
مصريه رواد في المجال ده كل الناس اللي
انا شايفهم كانوا ياما امريكان ياما
اوروبيين ناس مش زيي خالص فبالتالي انا
كان دايما عندي نوع من الحاجز النفسي
اتجاه اللي انا اصلا ادخل المجال ده وده
كان بيخليني احس ان في طريق واحد بس ممكن
اسلك فيه او في طريق ممكن الناس حواليا
برض يعني كلنا كان عندنا احساس بالعجز ا
اللي احنا ندخل مجالات جديده نسبيا ما
فيهاش ناس مصريين ولكن الحقيقه ان ده مش
حقيقه خالص ان في مصريين كتيره في المجال
ده ولكن للاسف معظمهم بره مصر ده يعني
لعدم وجود فرص كافيه في المجال ده في مصر
فان لما افتكرت بعد حواري مع ريب ده وبعد
ما افتكرت احساسي بالعجز ساعتها قلت انا
محتاج اوري للناس اللي داخله المجال ده لا
ان في حاجات تانيه في ناس تانيه في ناس
زيهم من الخلفيه بتاعتهم ممكن وصلوا
وعملوا انجازات كبيره وممكن الناس دي تب
زيهم فهنا مثلا في امثله لبعض الناس
موجوده على الويب سايت دي بعض الامثله في
الناس في الشركات فمثلا ممكن تشوفوا ناس
في مجالات مختلفه من الاي اي زي ريسبونس
بال اي اي او
مثلا الترجمه الاليه اوشن زي ممكن نفهم
مشاعر الناس من خلال وشهم من خلال حركه
جسمهم فحاجات دي كلها تحت مظله الا وفي
ناس تانيه
في الجامعات مثلا فمثلا الجامعات ممكن
نشوف ناس عندها
مثلا
وحاجات كده
ف الحاجات دي كلها ناس مشهوره في العالم
الاي اي ولكن ناس كتيره مش عارفاهم فانا
كان املي من ان انا اعمل ويبسايت زي كده
ان اوري الناس ان في طريق في طريق ليهم ان
هم يمشوا فيه ويعرفوا يوصلوا حاجات مختلفه
مش مش بس اللي هو الحاجات اللي هم
عارفينها اللي ممكن يوصل لها ولكن في ناس
زيهم جايه من الخلفيه بتاعتهم وفي طريق
ليهم ممكن يوصلوا يحققوا فيهم اللي هم
عايزينه ويسيبوا بصمتهم في العالم زي ما
ناس تانيه سابت بصمتها من
مصر فالحقيقه اللي انا الويب سايت ده ما
كنتش عارف اعمله لوحدي يعني انا ده مبني
من داتا كتيره من ناس في المجال ده
والداتا دي
كلها جايبها من خلال ترشيحات
ناس
هم بعتولي معلوماتهم فانا حاليا ممكن ا
بسرعه كده عن الويب
سايت الويب سايت حاليا لو شايفينه دلوقتي
في 98 باحث
مصري
والباحثين كلهم جايين من انحاء ههم دلوقتي
في انحاء مختلفه من العالم وفي مجالات
مختلفه من واللي انا عامله ان في اي حد
ممكن
يرشح حد انه يتحط في الليسته
دي الترشيحات
كلها بتكون بز على ان ممكن حد يزود حد
ممكن يغير معلومات حد وده بيز معيار
معين بعد حوارات مع ناس في المجال اتفقنا
ان المعيار ان حد يتحط في ال سيت لازم
يكون عنده اش
اندكس اكتر من خم ده معناه ان حد يكون
عنده تاثير كبير معيار بيحدد حجم الاثر في
المجال اللي هما فيه طيب نرجع
يداني ومكن شوف
ان اه ان اللي انا وانا بعمل الويب
سايت الحقيقه ان انا مش عايز اقف عند اي
والحقيقه ان في مجالات كتيره تانيه ناس
محتاجه تشوف ناس زيها من مصر او من جنسيات
تانيه
ممكن يعني
تحاول تشوف ان في طريق ليهم برضو فالويب
سايت ده معمول اوبن سورس بمعنى ان الكود
بتاعه موجود اون لاين اي حد ممكن ياخده وو
حد فيفهم ازاي ممكن يعمل ويب سايت ممكن ي
دبت الويب سايت ده لاي مجال تاني فمثلا لو
فكرتوا ممكن يكون في مثلا حاجه زي مصريين
في الارتك مصريين في السوسيولوجي او مثلا
عرب في الاجب تولوجي ا كان يعني في امثله
كثيره ممكن الناس تخل الويب سيت تعمل
حاجات شبيهه فانا مثلا في عمل فكره هنا
اللي هو اكس ان واي اكس معنى اكس ده يكون
جنسيه معينه وواي ممكن يكون اي تخصص مجال
معين فبالتالي لو حد يعني بطلب من الناس
ان لو حد عنده اي فكره او حد عايز يعمل
كلموني وانا اسعدكم وشوف ازاي ممكن نحقق
الموضوع ده في مجالات تانيه كتير والحقيقه
ان في اوردي في ناس ناس من المغرب بعتو لي
ودلوقتي بيعملوا ويب سايت للمغاربه في
الذكاء الصناعيه فوردي الموضوع بدا واحب
قوي اشوف ازاي ممكن نعرف نوصل لناس اكتر
ونوصل لمجالات اكتر وازاي نعرف نوصل صوت
الجنسيات اللي مش واخده حقها في مجالات
كتيره فده كان هدف واملي من الويب سايت
ده وهنا عايز اقول لكم شكرا
جزيلا